and now another word from our sponsor
ladies and gentlemen
ah excuse me
you've probably never seen a film editor
at work
well he has to be a wonderful artist as
well as a
thoroughly organized technician
otherwise he can get himself into quite
a mess
what i mean
well bob that's uh
one way of getting into pictures
well it's about the fastest way i could
think of actually though i'm looking for
one particular shot and i think
ah there it is
isn't that a glamour shot though
it's oldsmobile's brand new four-door
hardtop the holiday sedan
all right folks action
i know how he feels he's talking about
the finest of all four-door hard tops
oldsmobile's 98 holiday sedan
no other hard top now produced is in a
class with the 98.
but says the proud owner to really
appreciate this car you've got to try it
out
so how about a date for a rocket ride
ah here we are one day later and all
ready for our drive in a new holiday
sedan you see how easy it is to get in
the back it's just like a regular
four-door sedan
yes just as convenient and roomy as a
four-door sedan but this is a hard top
with all the smart style and open-air
pleasure that you find in oldsmobile's
famous holiday cafe look at those long
graceful lines and that smooth rocket
action and look at the space inside this
hard top
real limousine compass
and by the way
you'll be glad to know that the holiday
sedan comes in all three holiday lines
the 98 the super 88 and the 88
and in this 98 interior we find the
beautiful new metallic cloth in smooth
rich leather
well we're off again
let's rock it away
say this is appropriate oldsmobile's new
holiday sedan is joined by its companion
car the holiday coupe
two great running mates two happy
holidays by oldsmobile
so you see there's a holiday for you at
your oldsmobile dealers right now mr
bowman listen lamar
now ladies and gentlemen
back to the academy awards and bob hope